ten people who insist the bar became too
far even though she's just a doll Barbie
ribs was pretty wonderful life she has
good looks multiple careers a beautiful
home and a hunky boyfriend children
aren't the only ones obsessed with Bobby
even adults can't get enough of her but
at some point the admiration for the
doll can become a bit too much if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
and give this video a big thumbs up
because today we'll be showing you ten
people who took the Barbie theme away
too far happy Anika's ooga since she was
just a little girl
Tatiana Sedova has been completely
obsessed with Barbie now that she's all
grown up she has decided to transform
herself into a real-life Barbie doll she
dyed her hair to look just like a doll
bought a bunch of Barbies style outfits
and her apartment looks like a
life-sized Barbie Dreamhouse in her free
time - even right Barbie theme songs and
performed them like she's a plastic doll
the barbie man shanlee caller-id also
known as he's bobbing in is embarrassed
to admit that he has been obsessed with
Barbie
ever since he purchased his first all
the happy holiday Barbie in 1997 in new
seven-bedroom house four rooms are
dedicated to housing his collection
which now includes 2000 Barbie dolls
he has spent over $80,000 on dolls and
anything that has Barbies name on it the
most expensive Barbie in his collection
is the penis blender doll which costs
him nine hundred and seventy five
dollars Rachel Evans what would you do
if you had an extra twenty five thousand
dollars in your bank account
some people would pay off bills others
would take a vacation to an exotic
location when a woman named Rachel Evans
decided to use her money to fuel her
Barbie obsession from a young age people
would call her the doll and as she got
older she decided to go under the knife
to really transform her look but being a
real-life Barbie is more than looking
like a doll rachel says she completely
embodies Bobbie from her heart her soul
and
personality Rebecca Chile's Texas mom
Rebecca - Lou has bit of barbecue
Lexington's 1985 he has a room in her
home that's dedicated to her Barbie
collection that valued at more than a
thousand dollars he's so in love with
Barbies image that every week she gets
her hair styled exactly like one of her
dolls then she has a custom outfit
designed to match the dolls clothing
Rebecca's love for Barbies goes further
than her desire to look like the doll
she has made it her mission to rescue
Barbies that have been dumped in
landfills and trash cans so far she has
found cleaned up and rescued over 8,800
Barbie dolls in total Elena's Kowalewski
transforming into Barbie came queasy for
Alina Kowalewski he says she already had
the big eyes little nose small plump
lips and long hair just like the doll
Alena claims she has never gone under
the knife
she just naturally looks like Bobby hmm
can you find that hard to believe but
we'll take her word for it Nanette
Kennan mother of four Nanette Hammond is
living life as a human Barbie you
replicate the dolls look the net had
three breast augmentation surgeries to
take increased chest size to 28 eight
veneers lip fillers eyelash extensions
hair extensions and daily visits to the
tanning bed inside her 10 bedroom house
she has spent over four hundred and
ninety four thousand dollars in total on
plastic surgery procedures and a classy
pink Barbie car
pixee fox' glamour model pixee fox'
had several boob jobs to increase her
brush size to 30 day six ribs removed to
make her wages tiniest Barbies permanent
iron plants the painter eye color pink
cartoon genes and 100 other procedures
to nail Barbies entire look she has
spent nearly one hundred and twenty-five
thousand dollars of plastic surgery
procedures most of which was donated by
her male fans although barbie has found
love with ken pixie hasn't been as lucky
in the romance department
he has given up on love and now here's a
home with fellow Bari fanatics Justin
jedlica guest has gone through numerous
procedures of his own to replicate Jen's
appearance together these two are the
real-life Barbie and Ken's Valerie
Lukyanova Valeria Lukyanova made
headlines worldwide for looking like a
real-life Barbie doll the Ukrainian
model has kept most of her plastic
surgery procedures a secret and she says
he doesn't see the resemblance between
her and the famous doll even though she
doesn't think she really looks like
Bobbie the rest of the world disagrees
and she has been labeled the human
Barbie Isuzu Sakamoto Los Angeles based
nail artist azusa Sakamoto has spent
seventy thousand dollars in total on her
Barbie obsession she has been collecting
all things Bobbie related confused
fifteen years old one look at her
Instagram account and you can tell Asuza
is serious about her love for the doll
her house has been turned into a Barbie
shrine completed Barbie teams home
furnishings appliances 145 dolls and 60
Barbie handbags
blondie cynic blondie Bennett is
dedicated her life to replicating
Barbies entire look
she has spent over $30,000 in plastic
surgery procedures including chin
liposuction size breast augmentations
and hypnotherapy sessions to make her
feel more 50 and confused
just like the doll Blarney says her
dream is to become as brainless as
possible and the only way to achieve
that is to spend a fortune on hypnosis
sessions which of these Barbie impressed
people shocked you the most react in the
comments section down below and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up
you